各位喔,我今天請小祕書選訓達
結果今天的訓達實在是太快殺了
他們有一段時間有稍微上來
那個點我就有空他
今天訓達很可惜,他沒有拉到盤上來
在7月禮拜五的
禮拜五這裡喔,這裡有他的買盤捷徑
寰宇買盤捷徑點在這裡
那各位看一下,這邊有個捷徑點
那買盤捷徑就是連次量爆量
連次量爆量
像這邊13,443
然後我們會空在它漲不上去的點
像這裡一直拉
我們來看
你看這一段
這邊一直拉
它的速度會很快
漲的速度很快的時候
不是一個好的進場點
那你要空的時候
最好是空它拉高
這邊各位你都可以回放看五檔的狀況
我們是會空在它漲不上去的那個點
空在它連次量爆量
然後價格推不上去
你看到這邊其實
這買賣的價格在這邊撐很久你可以看我一買158這邊181張那撐一撐一直上不去之後他的內盤就被擊潰了那一擊潰之後就會變成第一次的大量出現
那第一次的大量出現呢
他就是一個買盤的捷徑點
他有一個第一次的內盤大量
那這邊就是一個買盤捷徑點的出現
各位你看這邊是15次473
15次的意思是說
我們每5秒計算一次
內盤的成交量的PK
那15次就是多方已經連15次獲勝
多方連15次獲勝本來後面就容易有捷徑
那我們再往下看
16次
然後17次
這裡18次
連量就排在第一名了
19次
創高
20次
然後再往下看21次
22次
所以這邊就準備要捷徑了
23次
好捷徑了
第一次的390
就是他這邊有人打大單出來
那時候就接近點
所以接近點各位呢可以從這樣抓
這個當成是很適合去抓轉折啦
然後呢比較困難的是你要去猜他今天是紅K還是黑K這個會比較困難那我們有一些猜黑K的方法也有一些猜紅K的方法然後這個是我們上課會教給各位啦啊你會猜的話再搭配當中神器應用
你可以抓在比較好的轉折的價位
好那我們課堂上呢就教你
如何找做多的
如何找做空的
如何找紅K
如何找黑K
會教你找這些標的
那會找之後呢
你的點位就會像這樣啦
有可能會停損的
我也不是每個都po賺錢的
又po那個停損的
這裡又類似這一種啊
就空一空
然後呢嘎掌停了
嘎掌停就停損的
所以我就寫人在江湖飄哪有不挨刀
你會遇到這一種啦
遇到這一種你就找機會停損就好了
那至少說你會抓點位的話
總是勝率會比較高啦
那我們有一些方法是
教你怎麼樣去找一些比較適合做的標題
那為什麼今天放訓達
訓達就很適合做啊
各位
上當中課的我們就特別講訓達還記不記得我跟你講說訓達再出現可K隔天弄爆他對不對那我們當中做多策略比較少我們這次還是有新的做多策略
歡迎各位來聽
當中會有特別講訓達
因為訓達的黑K呢
有他特別的癥狀嘛
我們就說訓達黑K很容易抓
你看是不是又黑K了
他又符合我們設定的條件
他紅K出來之後
他黑K機率就比較高嘛
啊黑K機率高你就開盤空就對了
開完空 尾翻補
然後這樣子獲利也不錯
只不過今天很可惜他沒有拉很高啦
拉很高的話當然會賺更多
那今天沒有像之前一樣
各位看他之前都是
還開個小高欸
這次連小高都不開了欸
然後可能太多人知道這一招了
今天直接把他空低了
他今天就比較弱
今天開盤47.25
然後最高有到47.4
首盤45.2
可惜啦 那今天拉高我一定是好好的K他的
那今天沒拉高我也是有K他啦
但是就沒有可以這麼多
訓打這種型態就是我們喜歡的型態
這個課堂上就有提了
台中場跟高雄場都有提到訓打
還特別提這一檔
結果這一檔禮拜二就出現了